feel like upping the stakes of your late
night skinny dips
well welcome to lake neos one of the
most dangerous lakes on the planet
here your cannonball might just take
thousands of lives
what makes lake neos so deadly
how much damage could it cause
and how bad a splash will you make by
falling in it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into lake neos
in the northwest region of cameroon
africa over a volcanic crater lies lake
neos
a small lake with depths of about 210
meters
crater lakes like neos tend to release
carbon dioxide due to volcanic activity
deep below
usually this carbon dioxide dissipates
slowly as the lake naturally shifts
but if the lake stays still enough the
gas dissolves into the water
and continues accumulating there
steadily turning it into a ticking time
bomb
so
what would happen if that water were
suddenly disturbed
neos is one of only three lakes known to
accumulate deadly levels of carbon
dioxide
agitating this kind of lake could cause
something called a limnic eruption but
let's not get too far ahead of ourselves
you'd have a front row seat to this
catastrophe
and without even knowing it you'd be the
trigger of a major disaster
as your body sank into the deadly waters
of lake neos the dissolved carbon
dioxide would rise to the surface
the lake would start to bubble
and these bubbles would cause even more
turbulence
have you seen the famous diet coke and
mentos eruption
yeah that would be you
a 90 meter water jet would explode into
the sky sending you flying as high as
big ben in london
we'll say you're lucky enough to survive
the drop but you'd still have all the
carbon dioxide to deal with
in 20 seconds all of the accumulated gas
would be unleashed in a cloud over one
kilometer wide
it would spread as far as 25 kilometers
away from the lake and it would travel
at a speed of up to 48 kilometers per
hour
silently choking most of the living
creatures in its path
if you were in a village nearby instead
of soaking in lake neos
you'd hear a strange rumbling sound
followed by the sight of a white mist
rising from the lake the deadly gas
cloud would then usher in a gust of wind
putting out any fire that might be
around you
this is because carbon dioxide gas is
heavier than air and at high
concentrations it displaces oxygen
no oxygen means no combustion and no
fire
but it also means you wouldn't be able
to breathe
you would drop dead after a single gasp
of air
this is exactly what happened in 1986
when a landslide or an earthquake
triggered a limnic eruption on lake neos
in total
1746 villagers and 3 500 livestock died
instantly
no one was there to witness how its
usually serene blue waters turned red
from all the iron turned up from the
bottom
still up for a swim at the most
dangerous lake on earth
well the lake neos disaster happened
when the concentration of carbon dioxide
in the lake was at its highest
and since 1986 some safety measures have
been taken to avoid this happening again
like a pipe at the bottom of the lake
that now allows the gas to escape safely
still i wouldn't recommend risking your
life for this experiment
even with some of the gas being vented
neos has just way too much carbon
dioxide
maybe you could push your luck by going
for a dip at another dangerous lake
lake natron
hint uh it could turn you to stone
but
that's a story
for another
what if
you